now is time to do what matters most
all right here we go america's crime
crisis as you see president biden in new
york city because of it vowing to invest
more money into police departments
across america
the answer is not to defund the police
it's to give you the tools the training
the funding
to be partners to be protectors we want
to crack down on the flow of firearms
used to commit violence i don't think he
memorized the copy just me great start
president biden but solving this crisis
begins with putting criminals behind
bars we thought focusing just on guns
will not do this it will not get us
anywhere now the president promises in
the next coming days uh promise comes
just days
after wilbert mora was laid to rest he
was the sixth nypd office nypd officer
shot and second killed so far this year
now as cops face a dramatic increase in
ambushes across the country karina mora
wilbert's sister blaming the system
how many will birds how many jasons
how many more officers have to lose
their lives before this system changes
wish we had the answer to that
we've heard it time and time again
soft on crime prosecutors and you can
see a list of repeat offenders right
here on this giant wall these are the
names that keep coming up each and every
day in our news reports but nothing
seems to change but what about the
lawmakers don't they have a say in this
eric adams the new mayor seems to get it
these officers every day put on their
uniform pin that shield on their chest
put that bulletproof vest on and go back
in the streets with all of that
frustration
they still go back and do their job
now it's time for lawmakers to do their
job
the key is to refund not defund the
police got a long list of democrats who
have called for defunding dismantling
reimagining and eliminating them
democrats are responsible for the blood
running through the streets and the
subways now look you could go ahead and
play sound bites from all these men and
women over the last two years are we
going to get some law and order and is
it going to be restored in our streets
when you call them out mr president when
you go ahead and do that then i'll know
you're serious about crime we move ahead
now to mandate mania yes mandate mania
in many ways remember when we were told
lockdowns were our only tool our best
available tool to stop the chinese
pandemic the fact that we shut down when
we did and the rest of the world did has
saved hundreds of millions of infections
and millions of lives
well johns hopkins released a study
exposing what we already knew that the
pain the sacrifice the mandates in the
mask all useless turns out shutting down
only reduced cova debts by 0.2 percent i
repeat 0.2 percent you missed a wedding
couldn't make a funeral couldn't go to
the hospital too bad it was all for
nothing but if you're not watching fox
you might not know that because the
media blacked out that study how
convenient they just didn't have time to
do it too many scandals especially when
it comes to cnn perhaps some schools are
not even dropping vaccine mandates now
the cases and hospitalizations are
dropping rapidly look at the stats we
have to transition now to living our
full lives with the virus not hiding
from it that means
back to work back to school back to life
like sweden like denmark like the uk and
remember that convoy of ticked off
truckers who were protesting vaccine
mandates in canada their gofundme page
which raised over 10 million dollars was
suspended because their content
promotes
and supports
violence
whatever that means they virtually shut
off the canadian capital of ottawa they
know what we know that vaccines are a
choice the pandemic can't be eliminated
but it's our decision to intelligently
live with it in my view now
to the crosshairs of conflict let's talk
about it where the biden administration
faces a dueling threat
first terrorism the president announcing
the u.s special forces killed a key isis
leader in syria just as the terror group
is regaining ground in the middle east
take a look at this compound before the
raid right now take a look at it after
the raid
pretty impressive
how did we know
that the head of isis was there well we
have a presence there we have troops and
where are the terrorists going to go to
afghanistan where we have let me see
zero troops and we stranded thousands of
our allies go figure and this story
second now but probably first in your
mind especially if you're a european
ukraine the biden administration
authorized u.s troops to help defend our
european allies as russia moves special
forces soldiers right near the belarus
border now senator marco rubio after a
briefing you know he's from florida
calling this the most significant threat
in europe since 1945 and as vladimir
putin points the finger at the u.s for
starting trouble which is ridiculous the
white house points it right back at them
there is one aggressor here that
aggressor is russia
they are the ones who have gathered tens
of thousands of troops on the border
no kidding lots of finger pointing
i would love to point to some progress
meanwhile to this
super bowl football super bowl 56 now
usually the week before the super bowl
is kind of a dead week not this week tom
brady gave us something to talk about
the goat finally calling it quits after
22 seasons at least for now but an even
bigger story overtook the airwaves
accusation of widespread racism by
former dolphins head coach brian flores
he claims the league officially
discriminates racially discriminates i
should say against black employees and
black coaches and even compared the
league to
a plantation that exploits black labor
and ladies and gentlemen that's what
matters most hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now